[Música]
en su tercer partido de las
eliminatorias para el mundial 2022 en
qatar argentina perdió sus dos primeros
puntos tras haber ganado en encuentros
anteriores ante ecuador y bolivia
la albiceleste empató 1-1 este jueves
con paraguay en la bombonera el estadio
de boca juniors en buenos aires ambos
goles fueron en el primer tiempo por
paraguay convirtió ángel romero de penal
en el minuto 21 y 20 minutos más tarde
de cabeza empató nicolás gonzález para
argentina por un rodillazo del paraguayo
ángel romero que le provocó una fractura
en la zona lumbar el argentino ezequiel
palacio pasará varios meses sin poder
jugar ni en la eliminatoria ni en su
club el bayer leverkusen de alemania la
próxima fecha de las eliminatorias para
argentina es el próximo 17 de noviembre
cuando deberá enfrentar al seleccionado
de perú en lima
[Música]
colombia recibía como favorita a uruguay
que llegaba al partido mermada por
lesiones de jugadores como el madridista
efe de valverde y por el siempre difícil
juego que provoca el calor de la ciudad
de barranquilla en la costa caribe sin
embargo las dos veces campeona del mundo
se fue de colombia demostrando que
quiere estar en el mundial de qatar 2020
y pudo seguir maravillando al
seleccionador portugués de colombia
carlos queiróz quien se ha declarado
admirador del maestro tabárez el
director técnico uruguayo 03 fue el
resultado para los uruguayos en el que
sus dos delanteros estrellas luis suárez
y edison cavani anotaron los primeros
tantos del partido esta es la primera
derrota de colombia tras ganar a
venezuela y empatar con chile sin
embargo el tropiezo en casa puede
complicar sus aspiraciones ya que la
próxima jornada del 17 de noviembre se
enfrentará a ecuador en quito selección
que se encuentra en un gran estado de
forma
[Música]
en el poder de inspiración volvió de 17
millones de fanáticos con la victoria de
la tri y ante bolivia 3 por 2 en el
arranque de las eliminatorias de cara al
mundial qatar-2022 ecuador suma 6 puntos
en tres partidos de eliminatorias y
rompió con 11 años sin ganar en la paz
luego de la victoria ante la verde pero
la actriz debe mantener un buen
resultado si desea seguir soñando con
asegurarse un cupo para la fiesta
mundialista el próximo compromiso lo
jugará aquí en la casa blanca en el
estadio rodrigo paz delgado la capital
ecuatoriana el martes 17 de noviembre
ante la selección colombiana pero los 29
seleccionados gustavo alfaro han dicho
que darán el todo para enfrentar a los
favoritos un partido en el que se
pondría a prueba un plan piloto para
jugar con público con la asistencia del
15 por ciento del aforo a pesar que todo
estaba aprobado para cumplir con un
protocolo sanitario a causa de la
pandemia al aire libre
la decisión final estará a cargo de la
fifa y de la confederación sudamericana
de fútbol
[Música]